bonsoir fait il m'a benomar merci d'être
avec nous il n'y aura donc pas de procès
devant une cour d'assises au terme de
près de dix ans d'instruction la
déception est grande la compréhension
déception et incompréhension et alors il
faut savoir que ça se passe très souvent
comme ça c'est pour ça qu'il ya un grand
niveau de mobilisation pour avoir un
sauvetage à 15 ans c'est parce que très
souvent ça se passe comme ça et d des
qualifications on part du principe que
des gamines de 13 ans 12 ans 11 ans
était consentante donc celle qu'on a
surnommé julie ça a commencé il avait 13
ans on part du principe qu'il était
consentante à des viols en réunion par
plusieurs adultes donc ces pompiers
professionnels étaient tous majeurs elle
avait même pas croire 13 ans d'ailleurs
quand elle a eu le premier malaise à
l'école et qu'elle a fait la
connaissance de l'un d'entre eux et
l'enchaîner des crises de tétanie a eu
plus de 130 interventions entre 2008 et
2010 et l'a fait une tentative des
tentatives de suicide
aujourd'hui les handicapées à plus de 80
% parce qu'elle s'est défénestrée s'est
jetée par la fenêtre et dont cannes
un jour cela ce pompier qui était
intervenu l'emmène chez lui là il ya
deux autres de ses collègues qu'il
rejoigne et c'était le premier viol
collectif tel qu'elle le dit juste quand
on voit la correspondance de ces jeunes
hommes
il l'appelait la coche pour dire
[ __ ] et il faisait tourner son
numéro dans les casernes de la région
parisienne c'est comme ça qu'ils se sont
retrouvés à vingt pompiers qui sont qui
ont été accusés par l donc vingt pieds
tous majeurs qui savait qu'elle était
mineure et qu'elle suivait à un lourd
traitement qui la mettait dans un état
de léthargie entre autres donc là au
début quand il ya eu les mains au début
il ya eu un long de process pour pouvoir
mettre en examen ces hommes il y en a
que trois qui vont être mis en examen au
début pour viol sur mineure en réunion
ça fait quand même beaucoup de
circonstances aggravantes
jusqu'à ce qu'un jour le jour le juge
décide de requalifier en atteinte
sexuelle c'est quoi une atteinte
sexuelle c'est que
en gros on part du principe qu'il était
consentante et en accusant que trois
d'entre eux et les 17 autres étaient
relaxés sous prétexte que selon eux il
connaissait pas son âge alors que dans
les fiches d'intervention des pompiers
qui intervenaient auprès d'elle
l'âge est évidemment stipulé donc là
effectivement il ya un effet
complètement anachronique l'assemblée
nationale et tous les débats qui a eu
dans la société
je pense qu'il ya un consensus dans la
société pour dire que à 13 ans on peut
pas être consentante à des rapports
sexuels avec des adultes qui plus est
ddd des rapports sexuels à plusieurs
c'est des choses qui contenait
consentant à l'effet que quand on est
nous mêmes adultes et donc bah là le la
famille et les avocats vont saisir la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme et
j'espère que l'on va on va avoir gain de
cause de cette fois ci fait il m'avait
nos mars et toujours cette voix là cette
idée cette affaire du du consentement
qui revient sur le tapis du discernement
la cour de cassation en quelque sorte a
suivi la loi mais pourquoi la loi
française est elle aussi en retard par
rapport à d'autres pays européens sur ce
point du consentement justement pourquoi
les choses évoluent aussi difficilement
en france argue que y aurait un problème
de constitution parce qu' il faudrait
toujours dans les tribunaux qu'on juge
au cas par cas alors que c'est pas vrai
la plupart des pays européens ont un âge
minimal de consentement il faut savoir
qu'en france la des jurisprudences et
l'acte et que que hockey à moins de 5
ans
on n'allait pas prendre ça mais c'est
ainsi quand éclate elle et les scandales
de ces gamines de 11 ans qu'on avait
jugé consentante en 2017 et c'est comme
ça d'ailleurs que les français avaient
découvert cette incongruité dans le
droit français
donc là on nous promet de réprimer
enfin d'avoir un seuil d'âge à 15 ans il
y un rapport sexuel avec un majeur pour
qu'on ne débatte même plus dans les
tribunaux si elle était consentante ou
pas mais très franchement avec ou sans
loi là on aurait pu quoi caractérisé la
contrainte parce qu'aujourd'hui pour
accuser quelqu'un de violent
il faut faire la preuve enfin il faut
prouver qui a eu la contrainte l'âme le
viol par violence menace contrainte et
surprise sauf que la contrainte elle est
quand même induite quand il ya des
rapports sexuels qui sont exercées par
des pompiers des adultes c'est à dire
que à double titre il représente une
autorité sur une enfant qui avait à
peine 14 ans en premier aux premiers
viols en réunion et on lui reproche en
fait la première et auditions on lui
reproche de ne pas s'être suffisamment
débattue enfin imaginez-vous cinq
secondes de votre fille si vous avez une
fille de cet âge là à présent qui a
entouré de plusieurs femmes et
effectivement elle est tétanisée ne se
débat pas ce sont des adultes en face à
elle est donc la première édition on lui
a posé des questions au commissariat
incroyable c'est pourquoi tu n'as pas
j'y ai mis pourquoi tu n'as pas mordu et
pourquoi tu l'as pas pousser et quand
elle raconte bac elle est un peu
tétanisé on lui dit ah ben tu vois c'est
ça la différence entre ça et un vial
enfin moi j'ai été dans des situations
un très intimidante même à plus de 18
ans où j'ai je n'ai pas eu forcément là
ce qu'on peut appeler la réaction la
plus parfaite qu'on attendrait d'une
victime mais là on parle d'une gamine de
13 ans merci beaucoup
fatima benomar avoir été avec nous pour
commenter donc cette décision
aujourd'hui de la cour de cassation qui
a mené au moins un cas c'est le
en lieu dont ont bénéficié donc
plusieurs pompiers merci à vous